What's up guys? Morriszo from Pitchfork
Academy here. And in this Unreal Engine
5 tutorial, I'm going to show you how to
very quickly and very easily set up
moving platforms. So perhaps you want
some moving platforms in your game like
these ones that are just automatic and
move from one position to another. Or
you want a platform like this one that
when you step on is activated and when
you step off is deactivated like so. Or
perhaps you want a platform like this
one over here where if you press a
switch it will come over to a certain
position and then go back to where it
came from and reset and is able to be
used over and over again. Or maybe you
need a platform that goes from one
position to another and stops at either
end, such as an elevator or something
similar to that. Well, all of these are
very, very easily set up and shown in
this very quick and very easy tutorial
on moving platforms. But just before we
get started, guys, if you want to
supercharge your Unreal Engine learning
experience, our Patreon has three
membership tiers for added support,
ranging from basic access to our private
Discord server, Mizo's Dizo, to perks
such as unlimited use of our integrated
AI assistant, and even 60-minute
one-on-one consultations with myself or
Velocity on our Deluxe tier. And if
you're not in a position to support us
in that way, you're always welcome to
join our free public Discord server, the
Pitchfork Academy. You'll find links to
Patreon, as well as an invite link to
our free Discord in the description and
the pinned comment. But without further
ado, let me show you how to do this. All
righty, guys. So, I'm here in basically
a blank third person template project.
And for the record, I'm using Unreal
Engine 5.7. But everything I show you in
this video should be applicable in
literally any version of Unreal Engine
5. So with all that being said, I'm
first going to create a folder for my
moving platform. So I'm going to
rightclick and create a new folder. And
let's call this moving platform and open
this up. And in here, I'm going to
rightclick create a new blueprint class
of type actor. And let's call this bp
moving platform. and go ahead and open
this up.
Now, obviously, we're going to need some
kind of platform. And for this, I'm just
going to use a cube. So, I'm just going
to click add and add a cube. And let's
make sure our scale ratio is unlocked.
And let's make this something like 1.4x
1.4.
And bring the scale on the Z down to
something like 0.2
or even lower. 0.1. And just to get an
idea of the size of this platform, we
can go ahead and drop the platform in on
our level just anywhere like so. And I
might just move my player start over
here near the platform.
And to make our moving platform move, it
is literally just a built-in component
that we can add to this blueprint. So,
what we want to do here is click on add
and search for interp.
And this component that's built into
Unreal will uh basically just make this
platform move around based on what we
define in the details panel here. And
the first things I want to draw your
attention to are here in the section
called control. So, we've got the
duration and then the control points
that the platform will move to and from.
So, let's just change the duration to
something like 2.5. And if we go ahead
and add a control point here, you'll see
that each control point in this array
has this option. Position is relative.
Now, if you wanted to do this in world
space, you could, but uh this is set up
like this by default for a reason. It is
very very easy to use. For example, if
we put in two control points and we make
the first one 00 0 because it's
relative, it will just be wherever this
platform is placed in the world. And
then let's say we add something like 500
on the X to the second control point
here. And then compile and hit play. And
just like that, we've got a moving
platform uh that moves 500 units on the
X. And because it is set up to be one
shot here in behavior, it just moved
once and then stopped. But what we can
do is we can actually have a look at all
of these. So one shot, as you just saw,
just moves to the second control point
and then stops. One shot reverse does
a trip up and then back again and then
it stops.
And if we choose loop reset, it will
move to the second control point and
then reset back to the start and do this
over and over again.
And the last but certainly not least is
pingpong. And this is the one that I
recommend using even if you want some
custom behavior in the platforms. uh
because these ones here uh they kind of
deactivate this component once they're
finished. They're literally one shot and
uh I haven't been easily able to figure
out a way of sort of resetting them. Uh
the best results that I've gotten are
from using pingpong and sort of
manipulating this. So, ping pong, as you
might imagine, just pingpongs back and
forth between the two control points
like so. But I'm going to show you a
very neat trick that will make these
very scalable and easy to sort of set up
in your levels. And that is instead of
setting this second control point here,
I'm going to actually delete this
control point. And then I'm going to
head to the construction script. I'm
going to grab my interpter movement and
I'm going to add a control point
position here on the construction script
and I'll drag off of the position here
and promote this to a variable. And we
can just call this something like move
to pause. And this I'm going to make
instance editable. And I'm also going to
check show 3D widget. And what this
does, if we hit compile now and go back
to the level and we select our platform,
is you'll see this gizmo here that we
can select and then we can move this
gizmo to wherever we want and the
platform
will move to and from that position. So,
this makes setting these up in your
levels super super easy. I can duplicate
this and I can literally just if I reset
that
Ah, that's just reset the uh position of
the whole um platform here.
Ah, we've got the move to pause here,
which is relative. So, I reset that one
and then I can move that, you know,
here.
And this makes it super super easy to
sort of manipulate these platforms. You
can even make the time uh instance
editable. So we could uh what's this
property called? It is just called
duration. So we should be able to set
duration
and then this we will also make
a variable and we'll make this variable
instance editable. And then that way we
could make, you know, this one go for
two seconds and make this one go a lot
slower and take five seconds.
And there you go. Just like that. You
can whack this moving platform into your
level as many times as you want. And you
can just visually uh move where you want
it to move to and change the duration
down here, which is super super neat.
Like I said, very, very easy to set up.
But now I'm going to show you a couple
of other ways to sort of customize this
moving platform so that it activates and
deactivates when we step on and step
off. And also how to flip a switch on
the wall to turn it on or off and get it
to sort of do the typical things you
might want a moving platform to do, such
as work as an elevator. So, I'm just
going to go ahead and delete this one
here. And we'll just use this one here
because it's nice and slow and it moves
sort of just forward and back. Actually,
I'll just decrease the duration so it's
not doesn't take so long to test. But
basically, the first thing I want to do
is set this platform up so I can
activate it and deactivate it as I need.
So, if we open up the moving platform
blueprint and we select the interpreter
movement here, what we want to do is
scroll down and take a look at the
settings here under component tick and
also auto activivate here. Now, I found
this to be quite fiddly, but basically
if this is auto activated, it will just
start moving no matter what. So, we want
to deactivate
autoactivate if we want any kind of
custom behavior because it makes it uh
very annoying to play with indeed. And
the other thing I want to disable here
is start with tick enabled. So this is a
very very easy trick to basically make
this platform switch on and off is to
deactivate auto activation and then
start without tick enabled and then when
we enable tick it will just start
moving. So basically we're going to need
two custom events here. We'll create one
and we'll call this enable movement.
And we'll create another custom event
and we'll call this disable
movement.
And on enable movement, we want to
activate this component and also uh set
tick enabled to true. But first, let's
just check if it already is active.
Because if it is, we don't need to
activate it again. So, we'll drag off of
here and get is active.
Drag off of the return value and press B
to get a branch. Plug this in. And if
this is not active, let's
activate.
And you will want to check reset here.
this uh will uh not work if you uncheck
this I believe. So we'll plug that in
and then uh once this is activated what
we want to do get our interpter movement
again and we will uh set component tick
enabled
to true. Plug this in here and also if
this is already active we also want to
do it like so. And then we can just
duplicate these two down here. And oops.
And set this enabled to false.
And now let's try these out um by just
adding a box collision to our platform.
So I'll add a box collision.
And this, let's just, you don't want
this to sit too far above the top of the
platform because then the platform will
switch on and off when your character is
not quite on there yet. So, I'm going to
make this nice and snug along the
surface like so. And I'll just make it
so that it's not sticking out of the
bottom as well. Let's turn off grid
snapping and just make this stick just
above the surface like so. And then what
we can do is select our box. Let's add
an on component begin overlap
and also an on component end overlap.
And we'll just check if the other actor
is equal to the player character. get
player character.
And if it is, let's enable movement.
Enable movement. And then we can just
duplicate these three nodes
down here. Plug this in and plug the
other actor into the equals. And we can
disable movement.
And that should be all that's required.
Let's hit compile and play. We jump on.
H. It is not moving. What's happening
here? Ah, it was literally just my
collision was a little too snug against
the uh against the platform here. So, I
just shifted that up ever so slightly.
Was a little bit too streamlined. But if
I jump on the platform starts moving and
if I jump off it stops moving like so.
So you can see that functionality is
working well there. Now let's go ahead
and start sort of manipulating the
behavior of this platform to get a few
different results. For example, the
first thing I want to do is instead of
using end overlap to disable movement,
what I'm going to do is make the
platform stop at each end of its travel.
And how we can do that is this interp
has some built-in event dispatches. And
what we can do is get our interp to
movement and drag off of here and search
for assign. And you can see uh the
various event dispatches that are built
in here. The one I'm most interested in
is interp to reverse. This fires when
the platform reverses direction at
either end of its control points. So if
we select this one here, uh it will
automatically create an event. We can
bind this on event begin play.
And what we can do here when it reverses
is just disable our
movement.
And now uh the platform will activate
when we step on and then it will
deactivate uh when it reaches the end of
its travel. So let's try that out. Moves
to one end and then it's off and we can
step off. And if we step back on, it
moves back to the other end and then
stops. Pretty neat. So, it's kind of
like a oneshot uh except, you know, we
can control when the platform starts
moving again. Really, really nice. And
if you wanted this to sort of just go up
and back kind of like the oneshot
reverse except reusable, what you can do
is use this time here on the event
dispatcher. Now this is zero at the
start of the platform's travels and when
it is at the second control point it
equals one. So what we can do for
example is check that this is not equal
to one and get a branch and if it is not
equal to one then disable the movement
and that will make our platform go sort
of up and back
and then switch off.
Very very nice.
All righty. And now the last thing I
want to show you guys is activating a
platform with a switch that your player
can walk over and interact with. So for
this, I'm actually going to delete these
uh overlaps for the box. And I'm
actually going to um well, the box
doesn't matter. I don't need to delete
it because nothing is happening with it
anyway. But basically uh what I want to
do is now enable the movement with a
switch. And then uh what we can do is
just for now disable the movement at
each end of its travels. So we won't use
this branch for now. We'll just disable
the movement when the platform sort of
reaches the end. And how we're going to
switch this platform on is we are going
to need a switch. So let's first
rightclick create a new blueprint class
of type actor. And I'm just going to
call this BP interactable.
Now, if you've got a class of
interactables, you might have a switch
or a lever as a subclass of your
interactable sort of parent class. Uh,
but for the purposes of demonstrating
this, I'm just going to make one class
and call it BP interactable. I'll open
this up and I'm going to add a cube. and
the cube. I'm just going to lock the
ratio here and make this 0.05.
Something like that. Very, very small.
And this is just going to sort of uh
resemble our switch. I'll also add a box
collision so that we can interact with
this. And I'm not going to do anything
else to the components here. Um, that's
literally all I need is this little cube
we're going to see on the wall and the
box is so that we can interact with it.
So, let's put the switch. What I might
do is just
duplicate one of these objects.
And I'll put the switch
on the kind of wall there like so. There
we go.
And we are also going to need a
blueprint interface to talk to our
switch and also for the switch to talk
to the platform. So let's rightclick
here again and go to blueprint and
blueprint interface. And I'm going to
call this BPI
interact. Now again you might have
blueprint interfaces in your project
already. I'm just uh you know creating
this one to demonstrate that this will
work. I'll open up BPI interact and the
first function I'll call BPI
flip switch or something like that. And
I'll also create one called BPI
uh activate
actor. And this is the one that's going
to activate our platform from the
switch. And now that we've named these,
that's literally all we need to do in
here. We can compile and save this
interface and close it. And what I'm
going to do now is sort of work
backwards from the platform. This is
sort of how I like to work with my sort
of um my interfaces here. The switch,
the player is going to hit the switch,
and the switch is going to activate the
platform. So, I'm going to work
backwards from the platform to the
switch and then the switch to the player
and then put the um logic in the player
that will make us able to interact with
the switch. So, let's open up the moving
platform here and let's go to the class
settings and add our interface here
which is BPI interact. I'll hit compile
and then under interfaces here I'm going
to double click activate actor and
activate actor is just going to enable
the movement like so compile and save
that and then in our interactable switch
here again class settings add the
interface which is BPI interact and in
the event graph let's doubleclick BPI
flip switch And this is going to call
activate actor on the platform. And how
it's going to know which platform to
talk to is we're going to add a variable
and we'll call it actor to activate.
And this will be an actor
object reference.
And this is going to be instance
editable. And that means that when it's
in the level here, we can select it. And
we've got this instance editable uh
actor reference here. We can hit the
little eyropper and we can select the
platform. And then you can see there
that it's got BP moving platform uh
referenced here as its actor to
activate. So then we can get this actor
to activate and call activate actor
like so.
And then we just need our player to call
this uh on the switch. So let's also
find in third person blueprints BP third
person character. And just down here I'm
just going to find the E uh keyboard
event.
And we can get overlapping
actors.
I'm going to filter for interactable.
I can get a copy.
Get the first uh BP interactable that
we're overlapping with. And I will check
that we are indeed overlapping is
overlapping actor.
This will plug into other.
Drag off of here and press B to get a
branch. And if we are overlapping then
let's call our what do we call it? Flip
switch message
like so.
And I hope I didn't miss anything. That
should be working. If we go over to the
switch and press E, our platform starts
moving and it's going to stop moving at
the other end. If we press E again, it
will come back like so.
Nice. So, this could be an elevator. You
could have a switch at the top and at
the bottom, for example. Um, and you
know, you can customize this to do
different stuff. For example, uh, you
know, we we made this stop at either
end, but if we wanted this to go sort of
up and back,
we could do this.
And then for example,
uh, if we wanted to make this a sort of,
you know, a kind of challenge where
you're trying to get on as it comes
over, I might move the move to pause to
let's put it here.
And then let's make our duration
3 seconds. And let's see if I can do
that. So, this uh will go up and back.
It should. And then stop again.
Oh, easily enough time to get over
there.
Nice. And that's working very nicely
indeed. And guys, that's pretty much it.
I wanted to give you an introduction on
how to make these moving platforms and
how to customize them a little bit. And
I think that is job done. If this video
has been of any use or value to you
whatsoever, please hit like and
subscribe and I'll see you on the next
one.